nueva york- se blinda contra omicron el
alcalde de la ciudad bill de blasio
anunció que la vacunación contra el coi
19 será obligatoria para los
trabajadores del sector privado desde el
27 de diciembre la medida aplicará para
cerca de 184.000 empresas una
determinación que no es nueva para
compañías como google y facebook que ya
exigen que sus empleados reciban los
fármacos para entrar a sus sedes en la
gran manzana no podemos dejar que las
restricciones vuelvan no podemos dejar
que vuelvan los confinamientos acá nueva
york' tenemos que avanzar y la solución
es utilizar las cosas que funcionan la
vacunación funciona y las obligaciones
de vacunación funcionan
de cara a las festividades de blasio
también anunció que los niños entre 5 y
11 años tendrán que recibir al menos una
dosis de la vacuna para entrar a
restaurantes y realizar algunas
actividades extracurriculares
así mismo los adultos en general deberán
tener la pauta completa de vacunación
para acceder a restaurantes teatros o
gimnasios las restricciones son un
intento por contener el avance acelerado
de los contagios por ccoo y 19 en nueva
york' la ciudad se enfrenta a un aumento
del 75% de los casos desde el 11 de
noviembre
los anuncios dividen a los neoyorquinos
en que hay que mantener a la mayoría de
las personas a salvo y los científicos
lo han demostrado hasta ahora en sus
investigaciones entiendo que nos
mantiene más seguros y todos tienen la
vacuna
graba sectores extremos sabes creo que
es extremo me parece torpe y poco
elegante cerca del 90% de los adultos de
la ciudad ya han recibido al menos una
dosis de la vacuna de kobe 19